The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, well I'd like
to thank you for
inviting me again
to talk to the poker class.
It's always great to
come here, and we're
going to be having a
tournament in a couple weeks,
so good luck for the people
participating in that.
Actually, I'm coming
back in another two weeks
because I think [INAUDIBLE]
a Harvard MIT math tournament
for high school kids.
I really love visiting MIT.
I just wish it were at some
other time besides the winter.
Then it would be perfect.
All right, today
I'm going to talk
about the University of
Alberta's Cepheus computer
program.
It supposedly solved poker.
We're going to talk about
what they actually did.
[LAUGHTER]
There seems to be a
lot of buzz about this,
so I thought this
was a good to do.
So I have to tell you that Jared
and I did not work directly
with the University
of Alberta people,
but we are very familiar
with their methods
and have actually tried some
of their coding techniques.
So we're pretty familiar
with the same research that's
going on.
To It's sort of an, I
think, objective commentary.
So by the way, as
the lecture goes on,
you can interrupt
with questions.
Just raise your hands
if something is unclear
because I've been told
I have about 80 minutes.
Probably spend 55 and then
save the rest for questions.
All right, so that
line of talk-- first
I'm going to talk about what
the Cepheus accomplished,
what the University of
Alberta people accomplished,
and I'm going to bring that
up by discussing game theory
optimal energies in poker.
How many of you know
what game [INAUDIBLE] is.
I just want to know [INAUDIBLE]
or what a [INAUDIBLE] is.
Raise your hands.
OK.
So about 1/2, 2/3.
Good.
I'm going to do a quick
introduction to what game
theory [INAUDIBLE] is.
We're going to talk about a
simple poker game and solutions
to it.
And then I'm going to go
into their algorithm, which
is written [INAUDIBLE].
They used the method of
counterfactual [INAUDIBLE].
Actually, the method
they used to push
through to the
solution of the problem
is counter CF plus,
which is basically
the original algorithm with some
shortcuts, which we'll discuss.
After this, though, we're
going to think about extensions
of computer solutions to other
games, including [INAUDIBLE]
games and multiplayer games.
A couple people have questions
about [INAUDIBLE] no limit
program.
We'll talk about what they're
work entailed if questions
lead in that direction.
All right, let's talk about
what Cepheus accomplished.
It's a game theory [INAUDIBLE]
solution to heads up limit
hold 'em.
And so what does that mean?
You guys all know what
limit hold 'em is, right?
Good.
Basically, after
[INAUDIBLE] few years,
they've achieved and
exploited less than 1/1000
of a big blind.
So the first thing is not a
boo perfect optimal solution.
You can still exploit
it for about 1/1000
of a blind for a hand.
However, there are
probably better games.
This is like 1/20-- this
is 1/2000 of a big bet.
You can actually play heads up
for 50 years at normal speed
and still have some
probability of losing.
The reason for that is the
standard deviation of heads
up limit hold 'em is
about five big blinds.
So you can just
imagine how many hands
you have to play [INAUDIBLE]
the significance.
About, oh, 25 million.
So it's definitely a milestone.
This is the first time a real
poker game has been solved.
In math of poker, we solved
ace, king, queen, [INAUDIBLE]
on paper, but [INAUDIBLE] a
real poker games that's solved.
However, given
their previous work,
it was just a matter
of [INAUDIBLE].
I remember two or
three years ago
they passed the 1/100
of a big bet, which
is sort of our measurement
of significance.
If you're playing and you're
winning more than 1/100
of a big bet for a hand,
you can [INAUDIBLE] it's
a probable game.
Below that comes theoretical.
So it's definitely a milestone.
And basically I knew that,
if they just maybe spent
more CPU power, they
would get the solution.
For 900 CPU years, we
finally got the solution.
So I don't know.
If I had that much CPU power,
I'd solve a few problems, too.
But it's still the
miles [INAUDIBLE].
It's great.
So what effect does this
have on other games?
Does this mean poker is
going to go the way of chess
for computers who are just
much better than we are?
I don't think we're
there yet, and we'll
talk about that later.
So let's talk about
Nash equilibrium.
So John F. Nash won
the Nobel Prize in 1994
"for pioneering
analysis of equilibrium
in the theory of
non-cooperative games."
And he extended the work of
John Von Neumann and Oskar
Morgenstern, [INAUDIBLE]
actually first considered
these two player zero sum games.
So Nash equilibrium is
just a set of strategies
such that no player can
actually improve their strategy
and make more [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] whatever.
In a the two player
zero sum games,
we refer to Nash equilibria
as also very optimal.
The reason is because
Nash equilibria are also
the min/max solution.
It's the best you can
do given that he can
see what you do and respond.
Simplest case of
Nash equilibria is,
if you're playing
rock, paper, scissors,
what's the Nash equilibrium?
1/3 each.
So that's not that exciting in
this case, because both players
kind of just t0.
You can't make more than 0,
you can't make less than 0.
So it doesn't seem to be
that exciting a solution,
but in poker it's
kind of exciting
because they're kind of
dominated mistakes people play,
or mistakes that actually lose
money to the optimal solution.
So the reason 1/3, 1/3
is the Nash equilibrium
because nobody can do
anything to improve their lot.
It may not be the
best thing to play.
If a guy is playing 1/2
scissors and 1/2 rock,
what should you play?
100% rock.
Yeah, sort of like the
Aerosmith strategy.
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
So there are much better ways to
play if your opponents deviate
from Nash equilibrium.
So actually game theory optimal
is not necessarily the best way
to play, even heads up.
It's a way to play to kind
of guaranteed you never lose.
So that's sort of
the accomplishment.
That's why we like
to find these things.
I know I could just
play this, and I'm not
taking total advantage of
my opponent's mistakes,
but at least I'm playing
in away where he can't
take advantage of me at all.
Let's do a simple example.
So this is an
example that I shared
with the class a
couple years ago.
So there are two
players, Rose and Colin,
and the reason the
players are called
Rose and Colin are because this
refers to [INAUDIBLE] games.
One player chooses a row, the
other player chooses a column.
That's their payoff.
And for a three player
game, we introduce Larry,
because there are layers.
So the two players
are Rose and Colin.
So each player antes
$50 for $100 in a pot.
Rose looks at a card
[INAUDIBLE] full deck,
who will win in the pot a
showdown if the card is.
Otherwise she will lose.
So Rose can decide
to bet $100 or check
after she looks at her card.
So there's $100 in the pot.
She looks at her card.
She [INAUDIBLE] whether
to be $100 or to check.
If Rose bets, Colin may
decide to call $100 or fold.
If Colin folds, Rose wins.
Well, you guys know
how poker works.
If Colin calls,
there's a showdown,
and her card is
actually a spade.
She wins the whole pot.
Colin wins the pot.
So what's the optimal
strategies for Rose and Colin?
Does anybody know the answer?
Well, let's do one
[INAUDIBLE] part of it.
How often do you think
[INAUDIBLE] should call?
Colin wants a call
[INAUDIBLE] enough to make
Rose's bluffs probable.
If Rose gets a spade,
what is she going to do?
Bet.
She has nothing to
lose by betting,
unless she's being
very, very tricky,
but it is correct to bet.
So let's see.
If Rose doesn't pick
up a spade and bluffs,
how often does that
have to succeed for it
to be profitable?
There's $100 in the pot.
She looks.
If it's not a spade,
she has to bet $100,
and how much is she risking?
How much is she going to win?
It's actually $100 and
another $100, right?
Because there's $100 in a pot.
Sure, she anted something
and made the pot,
but she's spending $100.
And if Colin calls, she's
going to lose the $100.
If Colin folds, she's going
to win the $100 in the pot,
or she could have just given up.
So it's 1 to 1.
So Rose should call
half the time--
I mean Colin should
call half the time.
Rose should bet to
bluff in a 2 to 1
ratio, because that's the
odds Colin gets to call.
So Rose should
always bet a spade.
If Colin calls 100% of the time,
Rose will just never bluff.
If Colin never calls, Rose
would just be every time.
So there is kind of
no equilibrium there.
If Colin calls
half the time, Rose
will be indifferent to bluffing.
She'll be negative $50
either way without a spade,
and then $100 with a spade.
Now, this is strategy
for [INAUDIBLE]
and the correct
strategy for Rose
is this ratio of bluff to
spade, which is 1 to 2.
So Rose should basically
bet half of her hearts.
She can bet the
high hearts, and I
guess with the eight of hearts
she can decide whether-- is
it the eight or the seven?
No, it's the-- yeah,
it's the eight.
[INAUDIBLE] with
the eight of hearts
she can decide whether to bet
or not like half the time.
So these are Nash equilibrium
and game theory optimal
strategies, and basically the
value of the game is negative--
is worth $12.50 to Colin.
Any questions about this?
All right, so these
are the strategies
that the algorithm
tries to find.
Let's go on to
the algorithm now.
Well, let's talk about what
[INAUDIBLE] optimal is first.
By the way, there will be
about five or so transparencies
[INAUDIBLE] of math equations.
So just suffer through these.
Those of you who understand are
going to enjoy the later part,
but let's just talk
formally about what
game theory optimal means.
So there's this
game function, u.
It takes two strategies, an
x strategy and a y strategy,
and it gives [INAUDIBLE].
If this was rock,
paper, scissors,
you would have u of
rock versus scissors
to be 1, so on and so forth.
It's positive for x and
negative-- x is trying
to-- x gets u, and y loses u.
That's the idea.
So one of things is we can
take convex linear combinations
of strategies.
That is, if x sigma
xk are strategies
and we have some coefficients
that are all non-negative
and that sum to 1, we
can make a new strategy
as a linear combination
of these strategies.
And also u is bi-linear means
that the value of the game
here is just the
linear combination
that [INAUDIBLE] sigma x.
And it would be the
same also for sigma y.
This just means, suppose
you have two strategies
and you play 1/3 sigma
x1 and 2/3 sigma x2,
your payoff is going to be
1/3 of the payoff of sigma x1
and 1/3 payoff of sigma x2.
Hopefully that's pretty clear.
Now we define a
pair of strategies
to be an epsilonic rim if
the best x can do against y
is this strategy.
The best y can do against x
is this strategy-- is epsilon.
And if epsilon equals 0,
these are in Nash equilibrium.
So after 900 PU
hours, what they found
were two strategies--
sigma x star,
sigma y star-- that
were within 1/1000
of a big blind of equilibrium.
And that's basically
[INAUDIBLE] accomplished.
So I'm going to actually go
through the nitty gritty of how
they did this in case you would
like to write on poker solver
Sunday.
So the big idea
that they borrowed
was this idea of
regret minimization,
which is actually pretty cool.
Suppose that each time
step t the player has
a few pure strategies.
We're assuming the player
has a handful of strategies.
In poker, obviously, there's
trillions of strategies,
but-- two to the
trillions of strategies.
But say he has two strategies.
He can play one or two.
Suppose it's odds, or evens,
or something like that.
Or he has three strategies
like [INAUDIBLE].
So basically he
chooses some sort
of mixture of strategies
at the beginning,
and we're only dealing with
one player at this time.
We're assuming the
other guy-- we're
assuming he's playing
against some adversary that's
all knowing.
That's the original set
up, regret memorization.
We'll talk about
how this applies
to game theory in general.
Now with each time t we're
given values ut of sigma k.
So basically after
he determines this,
the adversary decides what
the value of use of t is,
and basically his payoff
is just [INAUDIBLE]
a linear combination of
the things he picked.
But the idea is that the
adversary can be adversarial.
he can decide to make the
[INAUDIBLE] strategy score well
some of the time, and
the [INAUDIBLE] strategy
score badly some of the time.
So basically now the idea
is to calculate a regret.
By the way, this
is not the notation
that's used in the three or
four papers they wrote on this,
because I think they did
great work-- it's really
written as a math paper.
It looks like a particle physics
paper, which is-- actually
for particle physics you
need all the complex notation
because they're trying to
describe something [INAUDIBLE]
difficult. I think for
computer science papers usually
don't need this.
So I'll explain this,
and then you guys through
reread their paper.
I think that [INAUDIBLE]
give you a quicker way
to understand their paper.
So there's this thing called
regret of the k option
at time t, which is just the
sum of the difference of playing
k versus playing
whatever you played.
So basically you can
have positive regret
or negative regrets.
Negative regrets means that what
you played-- what you decided
to play up to time t was
better than just playing k
at each time step.
So we're only
concerned-- we're mostly
concerned with the
positive regret, which
means, instead of
playing, you should
have made-- you could have made
more money by playing option k.
So what's the
significance of this?
So the idea is we want
the average regret, which
is this element divided by t.
So basically you want the
average regret, average amount
that you're kind missing out
on to be less than epsilon sub
t, where in epsilon sub t is
the [INAUDIBLE] converging to 0.
If you have this, you have
some regret [INAUDIBLE].
So the cool thing about this
is you can do regret matching.
You can let these
weights-- first of all,
you just look at the
positive, the things
with positive regret,
and weight the options.
At each [INAUDIBLE],
we basically
weight the options that have
positive regrets accordingly.
And if you're so lucky that
nothing is positive regret,
you just randomly
pick a strategy.
Let's do an example,
because I think this
is kind of unclear what it is.
So let's just say we
have two strategies.
The player can pick
one, or the player
can pick two at each
time, or the player can
pick some mixture one and two.
After a player does that, the
adversary comes out and says,
well, one of them is worth
[INAUDIBLE] and one of them
is worth 1.
So let's just see
how this works.
So suppose at the
first time step
we picked sigma 2 because we
don't have any regrets yet.
We're just randomly picking
a strategy-- [INAUDIBLE]
sorry, sigma 1.
We'll just randomly
pick sigma 1.
So the adversary now gives
us the value of sigma 1 0
and sigma 2 is 1.
And you go, oh, well that
means that the regret
of the first option is 0 and
the regret of the second option
is 1.
We're aware this first option is
0 is because we already played
sigma 1, so you can't
have any regrets,
either positive or negative,
for playing sigma 1,
because your option
was playing sigma 1,
but you have some regret
of not playing sigma 2.
Sigma 2 was kind
of the winner here.
If the two [INAUDIBLE]
reversed, we
would have r1 equals 0 and
r2 equals the negative 1.
And then we'd become happy
because all our regrets
would be non-negative.
So at t equals 2,
because we have
zero regret here
and regret 1 here,
we actually pick the
strategy to be all sigma 2.
Now the adversary says, OK,
well the value of sigma 1 is 1,
and the value of sigma 2 is
0 for the second time step.
So what happens?
Well, the same thing
happens as before.
Now we have regret of
1 on the [INAUDIBLE],
and then regret of [INAUDIBLE]
on the second option.
So what do we do next?
The regret [INAUDIBLE].
Well, flip a coin or just
pick a linear even combination
of the two strategies, half
of one and half the other.
That's what we can do.
[INAUDIBLE] the same.
So now the adversary
says sigma 1 is 0
and sigma 2 is 1, which
means that the regret of 1
actually goes to 0.5,
and the regret of 2
actually goes to 1.5.
[INAUDIBLE]
1 goes down a 1/2.
So now with these
regrets our waiting
is kind of the ratio of the two.
It's 1/4 sigma 1
and 3/4 sigma 2.
So now the adversary
goes, OK, well sigma is 0.
Sigma 2 is 1.
So this regret actually goes
[INAUDIBLE] down by 3/4,
and this goes up by a 1/4.
And since this is
negative, now we
pick the strategy to be sigma 2.
[INAUDIBLE] and so forth.
Now the adversary
[INAUDIBLE] for us and say,
oh, it's really sigma 1.
Then a regret of sigma
1 would go up to 0.75,
and so on and so forth.
So it seems that the adversary
can make the job tough on us.
Well actually,
there is a theorem
that says, for our
example, [INAUDIBLE].
The square of the first
regret if it's positive
plus the square of the second
is always going to be
less than or equal to t.
And that's because,
if [INAUDIBLE] these
are both positive,
it goes, for example,
you are really going r1 plus
or minus whatever amount of r2
you're doing.
And r2 of t now minus
plus whatever amount of r1
you're doing.
The things that [INAUDIBLE]
this you can see the cross terms
cancel each other out.
This becomes 2 r1 r2
divided by r1 plus rt.
So you're left with this
squared plus this squared
plus this squared
plus this squared.
And this squared
plus this squared
is going to be
less than 1, so we
have this here, which means
that the quadratic sum only
[INAUDIBLE] by 1.
We have this bound.
Why is this bound so great?
Well if the square of the
regrets are less than t,
that means the average regret
is going to be [INAUDIBLE] 1
over root t.
In fact, it's kind of left
as a homework problem.
In a general case, our
kt over t is less than n
minus 1 delta over
root t, where delta
is the maximum
deviation of the options
and is just the
number of options.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious,
is [INAUDIBLE] in terms
of what is the strategy sigma.
Number of like a payoff?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
A strategy sigma, in
terms of poker strategy,
is sort of a description
of what you would do.
Suppose you get ace,
six off suit pre-flop.
A strategy would be a
descriptor of what you would
do at each point of the hand.
So there's some
significance in effect
that this regret, average
regret, goes to 0.
Well, the significance in
terms of game theory optimal is
suppose a peer's
strategies are--
suppose you have a bunch of
peer strategies for x and bunch
of peer strategies for y.
If we regret match, but
instead of doing an adversary,
we just say t
utility for x is just
the utility for x playing
against the sigma ty,
and the utility for y is
just negative utility--
the game utility for y
playing against sigma xt.
This is kind of a
mutual regret matching.
You do regret
matching for x and y
in each step, which
means you just modify
x-- you compute the
regrets at each step.
Then you modify x
[INAUDIBLE] y strategy
by this type of regret matching.
And basically the
strategies that you
choose, the average
strategy, which
is the sum of the strategies
you have had all along
divided by t.
1/t-- all the strategies
you've done in these t steps.
And basically what
happens is now,
if you try [INAUDIBLE] to
exploit a [INAUDIBLE] strategy,
again, this is the best x can
do against y minus the best
y does against x.
You compute this,
and you add the sum
of what actually happened
with x of t and y sub t,
and so on and so forth.
You notice that this is the
regret of k-- of x picking
strategy k all the time.
It's just y picking
strategy j all the time.
So that's less than
2 epsilon over t
because regrets over t converge,
so it's within [INAUDIBLE]
game theory optimal.
Basically what this all
means is basically suppose
you choose your strategy,
some mixture of stuff.
Your opponent tries to
figure out how best he
can exploit this strategy.
By the way, this is
often called nemesis.
I really like that name.
Opponent figures out his
nemesis strategy against you.
Then, well, you get to see--
so his nemesis strategies--
unless you're playing
the exact game
theory optimal strategies--
is always going to be better
than the game value.
He looks at what you've done
and finds the best response.
And you do the same to him,
and the difference of those two
games kind of exploitable.
Obviously, this means
basically, if your opponent
sees what you're doing, this is
the best he can do against you.
This number is the one
that's less than 1/1000
of a big blind.
So counterfactual
regret is kind of cool
because-- it's a good
thing I've drawn this tree.
At each of your decision points,
now you can regret match.
So first of all, you
don't need to be fed back
the correct utility [INAUDIBLE].
Here in the example we
gave, we had a u0 and u1.
You'll just be fed back some
unbiased stochastic number that
averages the value of the game.
For example, if you're doing
a regret chain on poker,
it's hard to tell if I'm
up with this strategy that
has a bunch of terabytes,
and you come up
with a strategy that's also
a bunch of terrabytes--
what's the value of playing
against y [INAUDIBLE]?
But we can just get a sample.
We can get a sample.
Well you can just run it once.
Right, that's the idea.
You get a sample by just
saying, OK, just play one hand,
and see the result of that hand.
And you could use either
random chance or whatever
every time you decide to do
whatever branches of your tree
if you do a mix tree.
So the cool thing already is,
without counterfactual regret,
you can quickly
converge the solution,
because a lot of strategies,
like fictitious play--
it's the best response.
The best response is hard
to calculate sometimes,
but each simulation can just
be one iteration through it.
And this is
counterfactual regret
because [INAUDIBLE]
is given assuming
that the player does everything
to play to that node.
So the waiting here is nature
just has its probabilities.
If your opponent plays
according to his strategy,
but when you play
you always kind
of play towards that node,
so your weight actually
1 for each of these
options you pick.
The cool thing is that once
you have the structure set up
where you're just doing
one or a few iterations
throughout the hand, it's
actually pretty easy to set up
different weighting schemes.
For example, if you have two
options and the ace of hearts
comes on the turn, or the deuce
of clubs comes on the turn,
and you don't really have to
worry about the ace of hearts
coming on a turn.
That tree is fine.
That part of the tree has
very little positive regrets.
You can say, OK, we'll
just-- different game where
the ace of hearts
comes about [INAUDIBLE]
at a time the deuce
of clubs comes,
but we're going to
weight the results by 10.
You still get the same answer.
It's just that you get a much
coarser kind of [INAUDIBLE]
every time the ace of hearts
comes, but already kind of know
what to do with that.
You can work on
the deuce of clubs.
So there a lot of different
weightings schemes.
This means that the hands can be
kind of sampled intrinsically.
So the final algorithm they
had was factual regret plus.
So instead of having
accumulated negative regrets,
basically a lot of these option
regrets can be really negative.
Folding aces pre-flop
quickly turns
to really negative regret.
You lose your small
blind, and hopefully
if you play it limit hold
'em, you could win more
than the small blind.
So you accumulate a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] so set options
falls off the map.
Their innovation in
counter factual plus
is to, instead of putting
a big negative number
to a lot of these things,
they just floor them at 0.
And the reason
they floor at 0 is
because you know this a
simultaneous evolution
of strategies where even
strategies at the beginning
just might not be
great strategies,
and you want to-- if
regret of something is 0,
you can route get regret
faster if it's the right thing
to do to respond to your
opponent's strategy.
All of these
things-- suppose you
start with a random initial
guess for your opponent's
strategy.
Then you actually have a
pretty reasonable strategy,
which is bet and raise
every time with every hand.
If your opponent has a random
strategy, he might just fold.
So later in the streets,
it's probably [INAUDIBLE]
just bet and raise every
time with every hand.
He raises you back.
It's not like he knows anything.
It's a random strategy.
Just raise him back
and hope he folds.
If he doesn't fold and
call, you bet again an x3,
because now the pot is bigger.
So he has a 1/3
chance of folding.
You should bet.
So that evolves quick.
If you start off with a random
tree with no information,
that starts off as
the dominant strategy.
And then you have to walk
that back as your opponent's
strategy evolves also.
By the way, they're
actually keeping
two trees-- one for the
small blind strategy,
and one for the
big blind strategy.
And this is everything with
respect to the small blind.
The small blind isn't-- so let's
just go into the next slide
probably.
[INAUDIBLE] have to be.
So let's try to figure out how
big the strategy space in limit
hold 'em has to be.
So let's concentrate
on river nodes
because that's
most of the nodes.
It's a tree so we just have
to calculate the leaves.
So first of all,
assuming a four bet cap--
the reason we assume a four bet
cap-- well, I don't know why,
but it seems that that's--
so this is one approximation,
the four bet cap, but this
is kind of normal in types
of research papers.
if we have a four bet, there
are nine possible actions that
get you to the next street.
There are some actions that
[INAUDIBLE] like player one
bets and player two folds, but
if you don't get to the street,
you don't get to the
river, and that's
a pretty small
percentage of the nodes.
So why are there nine
possible actions?
Let's count them.
One of the actions that gets to
the next street is check check.
So that's one.
What are the eight?
What are the other eight?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, check raise.
Let's try systemic
[INAUDIBLE] count them.
So I claim that there are two
ways-- one bet in the pot.
Player one can bet, and
player two can call,
or player one can check,
player two can bet,
and player one can call.
In fact, there are two ways
to put k bets in the pot
and k is greater than 0.
If you want to put three bets
in a pot, what are the two ways?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah, right.
Bet, raise, re-raise, call, and
check, bet, raise, re-raise,
call.
So if the cap is k bets,
there's always 2k plus 1 ways
to [INAUDIBLE] three.
So there are nine possible
actions in each betting
round before the river.
So there are three betting
rounds-- pre-flop, flop,
and turn.
So let's use some
symmetries because I
don't think the optimal strategy
has you playing something
differently with ace, six of
diamonds, ace, six of heart.
[INAUDIBLE] very easy to prove.
The optimal strategy
doesn't have that.
So using symmetries on a flop--
so how many distinct flops are
there?
Well, I like to think
about it as where
the suits have symmetries.
I like to think about
it as, well, there
could be three suits in a
flop, two suits in a flop,
or one suit.
So if there's one suit on a
flop, there's 13 [INAUDIBLE]
combinations.
That's pretty straightforward.
If there are two suits on a
flop, what's the combinations?
There are 13 possibilities
for one of the suits,
and there are 13 [INAUDIBLE]
for the other suit.
It's based on heart or
something like that.
The suits are symmetric.
So there are 1014
things [INAUDIBLE].
This is [INAUDIBLE] the things.
And if it's three suited,
you just choose three ranks,
but it's not 13 choose 2.
It's 15 choose 2 because why?
I guess the ranks can be equal.
So it would 13 choose 2 if
the ranks would be unique,
but you'd have
three aces on him.
So this is actually 15 choose 2.
So there's 455 three suited
flops, [INAUDIBLE] flops.
That's kind of the
big explosion in limit
hold 'em, pre-flop to flop.
So there is not [INAUDIBLE]
possible actions
in each betting round.
So let's count the number
of turns and rivers.
There's [INAUDIBLE]
turns and 48 rivers.
So counting that, you have
a billion possible action
sequences to the river.
The [INAUDIBLE] things in
each street, all the flops,
then the turns and rivers.
But each river, there could be
up to 126 [INAUDIBLE] types.
47 times 46.
Making about 6.5 trillion
hand river types.
Each node should be
visited about 1,000 times.
It's a big
computational problem,
but it still
tractable, especially
if you have 900 years of CPU.
And they also used
many shortcuts.
They use all the
symmetries I talk about,
and they also have
a few shortcuts.
And you can see
these trees are big.
Terabytes of memory to
actually store your strategy.
So you can't really
get that on a node yet.
I don't know.
Can you fit that on a node now?
Does anybody know?
I don't know of a CPU that has
[INAUDIBLE] bytes of RAM yet.
What they did was they broke
the problem up into about 100
[INAUDIBLE] different
sub-games, and they just
worked on those sub-games.
In fact, I guess if
you're clever about it,
you can use cache memory when
you get down to the river.
Things are pretty close, and
you know that using cache memory
is faster than using
[INAUDIBLE] memory.
You can take advantage
of these things.
A lot of these updates
through these regrets
are just simple addition,
and you can just
optimize the heck out of this,
and I'm sure they did it.
Let's just try to
solve some other games.
I have two games
that seem accessible.
Suppose we do Omaha eight.
Well, this is exactly the same
structure as limit hold 'em.
You just change the hole cards.
So instead of having 47 choose
2 different river hands,
you have 47 choose 4.
That's like a multiple 82.5
x to the original tree,
so that's not that bad.
900 CPU hours-- this is
just 75,000 CPU hours.
If it were a matter
of national security
to get the exact
solution to Omaha,
the military could just
do it in a few months.
There's also [INAUDIBLE]
you can do, by the way.
Basically, what they did
is-- before they did this,
was that they
solved the sub-game.
In that, basically if you
both get hands together
and you say you have to play
these hands the same way,
that's basically a sub-strategy.
You can consider
subspace of your strategy
x prime of x and y
prime of y, and you just
solved the x prime y prime
game, meaning you both get hands
together, probably on the river
because that's when bucketing
kind of becomes more necessary.
And you solve that
game, and you go, well,
how optimal is x prime
in the hold game?
And if you're good at bucketing,
it may be pretty close.
If you're bad at
bucketing, like you
put the aces in the same
bucket as seven, five suited,
you probably won't
get a great answer.
So you need to intelligently
design your buckets.
You can't-- well, I guess there
are also evolutionary things
you can do to try to design
buckets and see what things are
close to each other.
People who have
familiarity with this
know that this is
kind of hit or miss.
Another game that you
can maybe solve is razz.
It's definitely as simple
as [INAUDIBLE] a stud.
Why is razz simpler than
all other games of stud?
There are only 13
different cards.
The deuce of spades is the same
card as the deuce of hearts.
You can't-- well, you
could make flushes,
but they're irrelevant.
So unfortunately there
are 13 to the 8th power
possible ways of cards
can come, because there
are four up cards.
That's sort of the problem.
Kind of the
community information
you have is a bigger
set, and your trees just
get bigger because now
you have one extra street.
And you still have 415 choose 3
combinations of any three ranks
as river hand types.
So There are 2.4
quadrillion river hands.
So that's a factor
of 374 [INAUDIBLE],
but we think some of these
roads are pretty null.
How many of you
actually play razz?
A couple of you.
OK, great.
Good poker class that
people study razz.
If you have a queen up
and a deuce completes it,
you're not really going
to get into a raising war
and make it [INAUDIBLE]
cap on third street.
Some of the [INAUDIBLE]
may be null.
You can do some
bucketing, perhaps.
Razz is kind of more
natural to bucketing
because you can think about
what hands to bucket together.
Maybe the king,
eight, six, deuce
is very close to the
king, eight, six, ace.
And the two strategies--
and you can start in hands
by rank order of cards
or something like that.
So this is 374.
This is 82.5.
Or you could apply
for a grant and say
we need x hours of CPU time.
I don't know what the
right strategy is,
but these two problems
are tractable.
Let's talk about big bet
games because there's
been some sort of discussion,
even last night, about Snowie.
A few people have tried big bet
games, and they're problems.
First of all, there's a
continuum of bet sizes
you can make.
The Snowie solution just
assumes three bet sizes.
I can bet half the pot, I can
bet the pot, or I can jam,
I think.
Maybe there's-- I can
bet two times the pot,
but the problem with that is
that I think that's a little
bit too coarse.
The question is, if
you solved that game,
how close is that
solution to the real game?
And that's kind of an
interesting question,
but you don't even have
a complete strategy.
What if some guy bets
a quarter of the pot,
or 1.5 times the pot, something
that' not on your list?
You have to exploit-- and
then it gets kind of weird,
because my response
to a pot size bet
is to raise the pot again.
All right, what if he
makes a 1.1 times the pot?
Is it right to raise the pot--
just raise the pot 1.1 times
or raise the pot 0.9 times so
you get back to the same stack
sizes so you can do the
same thing in the future.
These are difficult questions.
Even if some bets
[INAUDIBLE] are non-optimal,
our full strategy needs
responses to to the bets.
So simple
approximations may work.
I kind of feel this is kind
of a tough problem, though.
And you could just--
just playing a game
where you can just make
rigid pot bet sizes,
then you might get something
actually interesting.
But one of the things
with regret matching,
if you actually have a lot of
bet sizes, suppose you say,
OK, I'm just going
to kill this problem,
and I'm going to do 0.01 times
the pot, 0.02 times the pot,
0.03 times the pot,
and so on and so forth.
The problems is now you have a
lot of options which are really
close in equity together,
so this regret minimization
is going to take a while.
It's going to have to sort
out really close events.
And then it's going to
have to balance your value
bets with your bluff
and things like that.
So even just trying to kill it
by putting a lot of bet types
may not solve the
problem for you.
So two player,
three player games
are actually kind
of interesting.
The dress by the group
and using counterfactual
regret to create competitive
multi-player agents.
And this is a paper
done in 2011 or so.
And the program for
actually first and second
in annual three
player limit event--
the first problem is that
there's no guarantee of epsilon
convergence.
You're not necessarily within
epsilon of Nash equilibrium.
Second problem is
that, do you just
want to play in
Nash equilibrium?
There could be multiple Nash
equilibria in multi-way games,
especially in these proportional
payout tournaments, satellites
where, say, two
people get a seat.
There are really
nonlinear effects going,
and it could [INAUDIBLE]
which collusive equilibria are
you playing?
In our book, Jared
and I point out
a game called the
rock maniac game
where it's a real
poker game where
players can use a simple
strategy and ensure you losing.
A simple version
non-poker version,
like a game where you play even
or odds with three players,
but the odd man out wins.
So suppose you and
I are colluding
against the third chump.
What would we do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, I would
play one, and you'd play two.
And the third guy
could never win.
There are situations which can
come up in poker like that,
but I think if
there's no collusion
and it's not a tournament,
playing Nash equilibria usually
turns out OK.
I think that's sort of the
argument they were making
in creating these strategies.
All right, here
are the references.
This took about [INAUDIBLE] the
time I estimated, so questions?
OK, let's just-- you
hand your hand up first.
AUDIENCE: Well, the
original strategy
finds that the Nash
equilibria, if you're
playing against someone who's
trying to beat [INAUDIBLE]
strategy-- does it work
if one of the strategies
is probabilistic.
Let's say two strategy trees--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It does work with--
AUDIENCE: Choose
[INAUDIBLE], but you
don't know always
which one I'll choose.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
works because you're
going to play-- all
of these strategies
assume that they could
be mixed strategies.
If you're not allowed to play
1/3 rock, 1/3 paper, and 1/3
scissors, then
you're going to have
to play really bad strategy,
and there's definitely
times in which mixing is
going to be necessary.
So, yeah.
All of these
strategies have mixing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What
effects do you think
[INAUDIBLE] going to have
on limit hold 'em games?
PROFESSOR: I don't now.
I think pretty much before
the solution came out
the big online players kind
of knew that a lot of people
were playing near optimal, and I
think the game is kind of dead.
What do you think, Mike?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Too bad Matt doesn't come here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] are
already basically doing this
anyway.
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
I mean, even if you have the
strategy, you have to learn it.
The problem is that, if you
go to a casino and you play
somebody who's a good
limit hold 'em player,
he's-- because these types
of strategies have been out
for a while, they already played
much closer to optimal than
they did before.
So I think this would have
absolutely no effect on heads
up limit hold 'em.
It's already kind
of no one-- yes?
AUDIENCE: So can you talk
more about different ways you
can do approximations.
[INAUDIBLE]
mentioning earlier bucketing
all of the different hands
[INAUDIBLE] the
ranks or what are
some other things we can do?
PROFESSOR: It's an
endless [INAUDIBLE]
be clever in bucketing.
So bucket hand types together.
One kind of clever
thing you can do
is try to cut out
the river entirely
by just estimating your
equity on the river.
Of course, that's not going
to be your showdown equity
because you may be
forced to face of a bet.
So you try some sort of
implied value of your hand.
Let's see.
What other bucketing things.
I mean, in some games there's
a sort of a natural way
of bucketing hand types.
Like In the river on
Omaha, you could just
try to bucket the cards that
actually play and ignore
the other cards.
The thing is that, when you do
things like that, [INAUDIBLE]
losing assisting, we
call it card removal.
Card removal and
blocking players
from having the nuts
and things like that
are pretty important--
do turn out
to be a pretty important
part of the game theory
optimal solution when
you're getting down
to the milli big
blind kind of level.
And if you don't think
about card removal at all,
then you actually
have a strategy that
can be exploited pretty easily.
Actually, I talked
about this yesterday.
The thing is typically
when the pot is p
and you're facing
a bet, you want
to make them
indifferent to bluffing.
He's betting 1 to win p, so you
want to call about pr over p
plus 1 at the time.
If you don't call
this much, he's
going to bluff and take it.
So that's sort of the thing.
We're saying the bet
is 1 and the pot is p.
So if the pot is
10, and he bets 1,
and he takes it more
than 1/11 at the time,
he's going to just--
[INAUDIBLE] bluff everything.
The real problem
becomes that, if you
don't think about
card removal at all,
he can start bluffing
hands in which he knows
it's more likely you have a
mediocre hand or something that
includes a strong hand.
One real example is
in PLO when there
is a flush on the board,
what's a good bluff?
AUDIENCE: You have
ace of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, you
have the ace in a suit.
You don't have anything else.
That's a great bluff,
because you're blocking him
from having a great
hand, and you're
blocking all of his
not hands and a lot
of his really good hands.
And he's much more
likely to fold,
because if you bet the
pot, a lot of his hands
he's [INAUDIBLE] himself with
[INAUDIBLE] with the nut flush.
Oh, I have a natural call.
Are you all in?
I have the nuts?
OK, I call.
So that's why card
removal is important.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is my
understanding correct
that optimal [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And has there been any
study of optimal [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sort of
like utility theory.
In poker in general,
it's kind of weird.
People think a lot
about that [INAUDIBLE]
what tournament
they should enter,
what games they should play.
But there hasn't
been a study really
optimizing your own personal
utility within the games.
The assumption is kind
of like, well, I'm
going to use all this cool
utilities theory [INAUDIBLE]
to figure out what
game I'm playing.
As long as I'm
playing the game, I'm
just going to try to
win the most money.
That's sort of
been the attitude,
and I think that's actually
correct for most [INAUDIBLE].
In limit hold 'em,
[INAUDIBLE] you
need bank rolls of
hundreds of bets.
You're not going to
try to optimize and try
to win some fraction of a bet
with your utility function
by lowering the variance.
That is an interesting
question, because maybe-- I
feel that, if there is some
utility consideration--
like maybe in a tournament
you feel your chips are
non-linear-- maybe
you are going to quit
playing your marginal
hands because of utility
considerations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] like the
fountain table of major events.
They'll go beyond ICM to
say maybe I won't coin
flip for a $10 edge
[INAUDIBLE] step up.
PROFESSOR: I mean,
if you use ICM,
those utilities are already
kind of calculated, but yeah.
For example, final
table of the main event,
I'm not only using ICM,
but I'm thinking, well,
$3 million-- $4 million
compared to $2 million
is a much smaller step
to me than $2 million
is compared to 0 in my
own personal utility.
Like $0.5 million compared to
$2 million versus $2 million
compared to $3.5 million.
So I need to optimize utility.
I mean, yeah.
I think that's kind
of worthy of study.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is it about
the analytics of poker
that makes it so popular
with trading firms?
And how does it--
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
That's a great question.
AUDIENCE: How do you
use it professionally,
all of this stuff?
PROFESSOR: Well, I mean,
I think poker is just
kind of-- if you think what
one game-- if you could teach
traders one game, what
one game would represent
what traders have to know?
Well poker-- there
are a lot of actors.
There's incomplete information.
That's one big thing.
And you do have to do a lot of
thinking of what your counter
party is doing.
If he wants to
trade against you,
he puts a bid or
offer-- some of that
is why there's this [INAUDIBLE].
Are you trying to
get out of risk?
[INAUDIBLE] big position
he's trying to get out of,
or do you have to be
worried about these orders
and things like that?
And also poker gives
you sort of the skills
to trade that-- suppose you
know something is worth $10.
[INAUDIBLE] you're going to
make around it [INAUDIBLE].
Knowing nothing, you might
make-- bid [INAUDIBLE]
offer at 10/10,
which means you're
willing to buy the [INAUDIBLE]
or sell it at 10/10,
but you know something
about the counter party.
You may know the
counter party can
be a better buyer than seller
or that buying is the risky part
[INAUDIBLE] is the risky part.
That kind of has a quant.
Also, as a quant,
doing poker analytics
is very similar to the
analysis we do in trading.
A lot of this analysis-- how
these strategies work, do
these strategies really return
what we think they return
are similar to discussions we
have in our trading strategy.
I'm glad I'm able to talk to you
about this, because if you're
interested in doing
poker strategies,
you'll probably be interested in
doing trading strategies, too.
Any more questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What about doing
the deviation from [INAUDIBLE]
the [INAUDIBLE] detecting
deviation or let's say somebody
goes from playing
optimally [INAUDIBLE]
not playing optimal [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean that's
a very interesting thing,
and that's actually hard
to determine because that
feels a little bit
harder than this
because this is [INAUDIBLE].
It's like I'm trying to figure
out the optimal strategy,
and I just play this,
and whatever money
comes to me comes to me.
You open your arms.
The money comes to you.
The other thing is, oh,
well he's playing badly,
so I'm going to go there
and take his money.
But then if I
deviate from optimal,
I'm also opening up
myself to being exploited.
So that's kind of hard.
That's much more of
a dynamic problem.
When does he go on tilt?
How long was he on tilt?
What evidence do we
have that he's on tilt.
I know that [INAUDIBLE],
the guys in CMU,
were looking into some
sort of zero loss way
to exploit your opponents,
because you just figure out
when your opponents
are playing badly,
how much they've given up
in playing sub-optimally,
and then you go
to a [INAUDIBLE].
But you only open
up yourself to, say,
half the money he's
given up, or something
like that, playing badly.
And the metric is-- so there's
some sort of gaming algorithm
you can do to do that,
but yeah that's definitely
another field of study.
There are a lot of interesting
fields that can come out poker
[INAUDIBLE].
All right.
I guess that's it.
[APPLAUSE]